et je me suis retrouvée, après ces cinq années de bataille contre le Parlement,
face à trois des plus éminents juges de la Haute Cour britannique
à attendre leur jugement concernant la communication de ces informations par le Parlement.
Et je peux vous dire que je n'étais pas très optimiste
car je connais les autorités. Je pensais
"Elles sont toujours de mèche". Je n'ai pas de chance.
Et bien, devinez quoi ? J'ai gagné. Hourra. (Applaudissements)
Ce n'était pas aussi simple, le problème
venait du Parlement qui ne cessait de retarder la divulgation des informations,
et ensuite ils ont essayé de modifier la loi, rétroctivement,
pour ne plus y être assujetti.
La loi sur la transparence qu'ils avaient fait passé et qui s'appliquait à tous,
ils ont tenté de faire en sorte qu'elle ne s'applique pas à eux.
Mais ils n'avaient pas pensé à la numérisation,
ce qui voulait dire que tous les reçus papier
avaient été scannés, et il était donc facile
de faire une copie de la base de donnée,
de la mettre sur un CD et de sortir tranquillement du Parlement,
et quelqu'un l'a fait, puis le CD a été vendu
au plus offrant, en l'occurence Le Daily Telegraph.
Puis, vous vous en souvenez tous, les révélations
ont duré des semaines, du film porno
au bouchon de baignoire, en passant par les prêts non remboursés
et l'aménagement intérieur.
En conséquence, six ministres ont démissionnés,
pour la première fois en 300 ans, le président de l'assemblée a été contraint de démissionner,
un nouveau gouvernement a été élu sous mandat de transparence,
120 parlementaires se sont retirés des élections,
et à ce jour, quatre parlementaires et deux Lords
ont été emprisonnés pour fraude.
Merci. (Applaudissement)
Je vous raconte cette histoire car elle ne se limite pas à la Grande-Bretagne.
C'est un exemple du choc des cultures qui se produit
partout dans le monde, entre officiels poudrés et emperruqués
qui imaginent pouvoir gouverner
sans curiosité de la part du public,
et qui sont soudain confrontés à un public
qui non seulement ne se satisfait plus de cet arrangement
mais qui, désormais, est souvent
armé de données officielles.
Nous avançons vers la démocratisation de l'information,
et je suis dans ce domaine depuis quelques temps maintenant.
Confession légèrement embarrassante:
Déjà, enfant, j'avais des petits livres d'espionnage
et je regardais ce que faisaient les voisins et je le notais.
Je pense que c'était un bon indice
sur ma carrière de journaliste d'investigation,
et ce que j'ai constaté depuis que je suis dans ce domaine de l'accès à l'information,
c'est que c'était un centre d'intérêt assez fermé,
et que ça s'est généralisé. De plus en plus de gens à travers le monde
veulent savoir ce que font les dirigeants.
Ils veulent avoir leur mot à dire concernant les décisions prises en leur nom,
avec leur argent. Je pense que la démocratisation de l'information
est un enseignement
qui repose sur les même principes que l'enseignement des Lumières.
Il s'agit de rechercher la vérité,
et non pas parce que quelqu'un dit que c'est vrai, "parce que je le dis"
Il s'agit d'essayer de découvrir la vérité d'après
ce que l'on peut voir et ce qui peut être examiné.
A l'époque des Lumières, cela a amené à s'interroger sur
le Droit de Roi, le droit divin des monarques à diriger le peuple,
sur la subordination des femmes aux hommes,
sur l'Eglise comme parole officielle de Dieu.
Evidemment, cela n'a pas trop plu à l'Eglise
et ils ont essayé de le réprimer,
mais ils n'avaient pas prévu l'arrivée de la technologie.
L'imprimerie a soudain permis
de diffuser ces idées, vite et loin, à moindre frais
et les gens ont commencé à se retrouver dans des cafés,
à discuter ces idées et à comploter la révolution.
De nos jours, nous avons la numérisation, qui ôte toute masse physique à l'information,
et c'est quasiment gratuit de copier et de partager cette information.
Notre imprimerie, c'est Internet. Nos cafés, se sont les réseaux sociaux.
Nous allons vers ce que j'appellerais un système entièrement connecté,
et nous devons prendre des décisions globales à l'intérieur de ce système,
des décisions concernant le climat, les systèmes financiers,
les ressources. Et imaginez -
si on a une décision importante à prendre concernant l'achat d'une maison,
on ne se lance pas comme ça. Enfin, je ne sais pas pour vous,
mais moi je veux voir plusieurs maisons avant d'y investir autant d'argent.
Et pour le système financier,
nous avons besoin de réunir beaucoup d'information. Et ce n'est tout simplement
pas possible pour une seule personne de retenir un tel volume
d'information, et de l'analyser pour prendre la bonne décision.
C'est pour cela que nous voyons une demande croissante
d'accès à l'information.
C'est pour cela que nous pouvons voir de plus en plus de lois de divulgations.
Par exemple, pour l'environnement
il y a la Convention d'Aarhus,
directive européene qui donne aux gens
le droit d'être informé, donc si votre compagnie des eaux
rejette des eaux dans votre rivière, des eaux usées,
vous avez le droit de le savoir.
Dans l'industrie de la finance, vous avez désormais plus de droits
à être tenus informés, il y a par exemple
les différentes loi anti-corruption, les règlementations sur l'argent,
plus de transparence sur les entreprises, on peut localiser les actifs par-delà les frontières.
Il devient de plus en plus difficile de dissimuler des avoirs, d'éviter de payer des impôts,
les inégalités de rémunération. Donc ça c'est super. Nous commençons à en savoir
de plus en plus sur ces systèmes.
Et il s'orientent tous vers un système centralisé,
ce système entièrement connecté,
tous sauf un. Devinez lequel.
C'est le système sur lequel tous les autres s'appuient;
C'est le système par lequel nous organisons et exercons le pouvoir,
et là je parle de politique, car en matière de politique,
nous retournons à ce système, cette hiérarchie verticale.
Comment peut-on traiter le volume nécessaire d'information
dans ce système?
Et bien, ce n'est pas possible. Tout simplement.
Et je pense que c'est cela qui est, en grande partie, à l'origine de la crise
de légitimité de nos différents gouvernements actuellement.
Je vous ai en partie raconté ce que j'avais fait
pour tenter d'amener le Parlement, à son corps défendant,
dans le 21ème siècle, et je vais vous donner
des exemples de ce que d'autres personnes
sont en train de faire.
Alors, il y a Seb Bacon. Il est programmeur informatique
et il a crée le site Alaveteli,
c'est une plateforme d'accès à l'information.
Elle est libre d'accès, avec de la documentation, et elle vous permet
de faire des requêtes d'accès à l'information,
de poser une question à un organisme public,
en vous facilitant la tâche, et je peux vous dire
que c'est très compliqué de faire une requête,
donc ça vous facilite la tâche, vous n'avez plus qu'à entrer votre question,
par exemple, combien de policiers ont un casier judiciaire?
C'est envoyé à la personne concernée, vous êtes informé
lorsque le temps de délai arrive à expiration,
l'historique des échanges est sauvegardé, c'est affiché
et cela devient une archive publique.
C'est ça l'accès libre, ou open-source, et ça peut être utilisé dans n'importe quel pays
où il y a des lois de droit d'accès à l'information.
Voici donc une liste des pays concernés,
et d'autres y viennent.
Alors si certains d'entre vous sont interéssés,
et que vous avez une telle loi dans votre pays,
je sais que Seb serait ravi de vous connaître
afin de collaborer pour développer ça dans votre pays.
Voici Birgitta Jónsdóttir, député islandaise
plutôt insolite. En Islande, elle a participé à
à la manifestation devant le Parlement
lorsque l'économie du pays s'est effondrée,
puis elle a été élue par mandat de réforme,
et elle est maintenant le fer de lance de ce projet,
L'Initiative islandaise pour la Modernisation des Médias.
Et ils viennent de recevoir un financement pour en faire un projet
de modernisation des médias internationnal, en prenant, à travers le monde,
toutes les meilleures lois sur la liberté d'expression,
la protection des dénonciateurs, la protection contre la diffamation,
la protection des sources, en essayant de faire de l'Islande un paradis de la publication.
Ce serait un endroit où les données seraient gratuites.
Si l'on pense à la manière dont les gouvernements essaient d'accéder aux données des utilisateurs,
ce qu'ils essaient de réaliser en Islande, c'est un refuge
où cela serait possible.
Dans le journalisme d'investigation, nous devons aussi
commencer à penser global. Ce site s'appelle ID
- Investigate Dashboard - et si vous voulez retrouver
les actifs d'un dictateur, d'Hosni Mubarak disons,
vous savez qu'il détourne des fonds de son pays
quand il se sait en danger,
pour enquêter à ce sujet, vous devez avoir accès
à un maximum de bases de données
d'inscriptions des entreprises, à travers le monde.
Ceci est donc un site web qui tente de regrouper toutes ces
bases de données en un seul endroit afin que vous puissiez y chercher
sa famille, ses amis, le chef de son service de sécurité.
Vous pouvez essayer d'y trouver sa méthode pour sortir ses actifs
de son pays.
Mais lorsqu'il s'agit des décisions
qui nous affectent le plus, les décisions majeures,
en matière de guerre par exemple,
alors nous ne pouvons pas simplement déposer une demande d'accès à l'information.
C'est vraiment compliqué. Nous sommes obligés d'avoir recours
à des méthodes illicites pour obtenir des informations, les fuites.
Lorsque le Guardian a enquêté sur
la guerre en Afghanistan, ils ne pouvaient pas se présenter
au Département de la défense et leur demander des informations.
On ne leur aurait pas données.
Elles sont donc arrivées par le biais de fuites, des milliers de dépêches
écrites par des soldats américains
au sujet de la guerre en Afghanistan, puis divulguées,
et ensuite ils pouvaient enquêter.
Une autre investigation majeure concerne la diplomatie mondiale.
Encore une fois, elle repose sur des fuites,
251000 télégrammes diplomatiques américains, et j'ai été impliquée
dans cette investigation parce que j'ai au accès à cette fuite
par le biais d'une fuite d'un gars mécontent chez WikiLeaks
et j'ai fini par travailler au Guardian.
Alors, je suis bien placée pour vous expliquer ce que cela représente
d'avoir accès à cette fuite. C'est incroyable.
Ça m'a rappelé la scène dans le Magicien d'Oz.
Vous voyez laquelle? Celle où le petit chien, Toto,
court rejoindre le magicien,
et il tire sur le rideau, et...
"Ne regarde pas dans les le rideau. Ne regarde pas l'homme derrière le rideau."
C'était exactement pareil, parce que ce qu'on a vu,
c'était tous ces grands hommes d'états, ces politiciens pompeux,
ils étaient exactement comme nous.
Ils se critiquaient tous les uns les autres.
Vraiment, assez médisants ces télégrammes. Je me suis dit que c'était
plutôt important de pouvoir comprendre que ce sont des êtres humains
au même titre que nous. Ils n'ont pas de pouvoirs spéciaux.
Ils ne sont pas magiques. Ils ne sont pas nos parents.
Au-delà de ça, le plus intéressant,
c'est l'ampleur de la corruption endémique que j'ai constaté
dans différents pays, et plus particulièrement
au coeur du pouvoir, chez les agents publics
qui détournaient l'argent des contribuables
pour leur enrichissement personnel, et qui pouvaient le faire
grâce aux secrets d'état.
J'ai mentionné WikiLeaks
car quoi de plus libre que de publier toutes ces documents?
Et c'est ce que Julian Assange a fait.
Il n'était pas satisfait de la manière dont les journeaux les publiaient,
sans risques et légale. Il a tout dévoilé.
Cela a eu pour conséquence d'exposer des personnes vulnérables en Afghanistan.
Et de mettre une liste des militants pour la démocratie -
ayant communiqué avec le gouvernement américain -
entre les mains du dictateur biélorusse.
Est-ce une liberté extrémiste? Je ne pense pas, car d'après moi,
cela ne veut pas dire renoncer au pouvoir,
aux obligations et à la responsabilité, c'est plutôt un partenariat
avec le pouvoir. C'est un partage des obligations
et des responsabilités. Le fait qu'il
m'ait menacé de poursuite pour avoir glané une fuite de ses fuites
montre, à mon avis, une incohérence assez notable
sur le plan idéologique, pour être honnête. (Rires)
Autre point. Le pouvoir est extrêmement seduisant
et, selon, moi, il faut posséder deux grandes qualités
quand vous passez à table, quand vous avez affaire
au pouvoir, quand vous parlez de pouvoir,
à cause de son pouvoir de séduction.
Vous devez être sceptique et humble.
Le scepticisme sert à toujours tout remettre en question.
Je veux voir pourquoi...parce que vous le dites? Ce n'est pas suffisant.
Je veux voir les preuves qui vont servir à justifier.
L'humilité nous sert à être humain. Nous faisons tous des erreurs.
Sans scepticisme et sans humilité,
le passage de réformateur à desposte est très rapide.
Il suffit de lire "La ferme des animaux"
pour comprendre que le pouvoir corrompt.
Quelle est donc la solution? Je pense qu'il faut appliquer
le droit d'accès à l'information dans le cadre de l'état de droit.
Actuellement, nos droits sont très peu protégés.
Il existe une Loi sur les secrets officiels dans de nombreux pays,
y compris la Grande-Bretagne. Nous avons cette Loi sur les secrets officiels
sans qu'aucun critère d'intérêt public soit appliqué. Cela signifie que c'est un crime et
que des gens sont punis, assez sévèrement dans de nombreux cas,
pour avoir publié ou fourni des informations officielles.
Ne serait-ce pas fantastique, et j'aimerais que vous y réfléchissiez,
d'avoir une Loi sur la divulgation officielle
selon laquelle les politiciens seraient punis
en cas de dissimulation ou de suppression d'information
d'intérêt public?
Pour que....oui. Oui! Ma pose du pouvoir. (Applaudissements) (Rires)
J'aimerais que nous oeuvrions dans ce sens.
Ce ne sont pas que des mauvaises nouvelles.
De réels progrés ont été réalisés, mais je pense
que plus nous nous dirigeons droit dans le coeur du pouvoir,
plus il devient opaque et fermé.
L'autre semaine, j'ai entendu le commissaire
de la police métropolitaine de Londres expliquer pourquoi
la police avait besoin d'accéder à toutes nos communications -
et de nous espionner sans contrôle judiciaire -
et il a dit que c'était une question de vie ou de mort.
Il a littéralement dit que c'était une question de vie ou de mort.
Il n'y avait aucune preuve. Il n'a présenté aucune preuve de cela.
C'était juste "Parce que je le dis.
Vous devez me faire confiance. Croyez-en ma bonne foi."
Alors vous m'excuserez, mais là nous sommes revenus
à l'ère de l'Eglise pré-Lumières,
et nous devons lutter.
Il parlait d'une loi en Grande-Bretagne,
la Loi des données de communications, une loi toute à fait scandaleuse.
Aux Etats-Unis, il y a le CISPA - Cyber Intelligence Sharing and Protection Act.
Ils se penchent même sur l'utilisation de drones pour la surveillance intérieure.
L'Agence de Sécurité Nationale (NSA) est en train de construire
le centre d'espionnage le plus géantissime du monde.
Il est colossal, cinq fois plus grand que le Capitole des Etats-Unis,
et ils vont y intercepter et analyser
les communications, le trafic et les données personnelles
afin d'essayer de découvrir le fauteur de trouble dans notre société.
Bref, pour retourner à notre histoire, les parents ont paniqué.
Ils ont fermé toutes les portes à clé.
Ils ont rempli la maison de caméras de surveillance CCTV.
Ils nous espionnent tous. Ils ont creusé une cave,
et ils ont construit un centre d'espionnage pour cerner, à l'aide d'algorithmes,
lesquels d'entre nous sont importuns,
et si l'un de nous s'en plaint, il est arrêté pour terrorisme.
Conte de fées ou cauchemar?
Certains contes de fées ont un dénouement heureux. D'autres pas.
Je pense que nous avons tous lu les contes de Grimm,
qui sont plutôt noirs.
Mais le monde n'est pas un conte de fées, il est peut-être plus barbare
que nous ne voulons l'admettre.
De même, il est peut-être meilleur que ce qu'on nous a porté à croire.
Dans tous les cas, nous devons essayer de le voir tel qu'il est,
avec ses problèmes, car c'est seulement en l'examinant
avec ses problèmes que nous pourrons les résoudre
et ensemble dans ce monde,
vivre heureux à tout jamais. (Rires) Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Merci. (Applaudissements)